[Music]  we've seen Emily Ratajkowski buried all  and one thing's for sure she loves the  skin she's in I feel very comfortable  she's in perfect et has a rundown of the  many times the model and actress has  wowed us with little to nothing on from  flashing her tone tush and abs in a  series of sexy bikini snaps to sporting  crazy cleavage while living it up and  can but nothing beats all the time she  stripped down to nothing for the gram  here she is relaxing in the bathtub  topless in bed bombing on the beach with  her sandy cheeks then there's this  making quite the entrance on the red  carpet in revealing yet show-stopping  gowns  still who can blame the gone girl  actress for wanting to show off her  incredibly fit figure when you have a  flawless figure like that life is  probably better in the buff and in the  words of queen bee  [Music]  you